bien alors on passe à vous monsieur
antonio tabucchi alors on commence par
le jeu de l'envers et l'orge et lisez
donc il ya des nouvelles le jeu de
l'envers et puis un court roman qui
scintille le fil de l'horizon
le jeu de l'envers a été traduit de
l'italien par pierre léglise costa non
pardon ciel et les préfaces hier à cette
année je me suis trompé oui alors ce
traducteur c'est céline chapus mis à
l'essai par lille chapuisat il préface
de pierre eglise côtoyé m'excuser bon
alors michèle gazier dans le télérama a
écrit un article très élogieux sur vos
deux livres et elle commence ainsi et je
crois qu'on peut pas mieux commencer
aussi il y h et antonio tabucchi de
l'érudit et du détective privé mais est
ce que ce n'est pas la même chose
certaine manière peut-être je pense que
oui et l'érudit elle et les détectives
cherche quelque chose
il s'est demandé il est ils ont un point
de vue interrogatif sur vesle réalité
ils agissent de la même manière
au fond il essaye de trouver ce qui est
caché oui ce qu'on veut leur cachet
vient alors le jeu de l'envers son onze
nouvelles très différentes les unes des
autres et qui ont cependant un commun
dénominateur c'est ce que vous appelez
le jeu de l'envers expliquer d'où j'ai
de vin versé tej et des mots qui qu'il
en joue n'est paix partout dans le monde
les enfants les jours un peu partout c
'est de prononcer les mots à l'envers
d'un dans ses nouvelles il s'agit de
voir
les côtés cacher des choses et l'autre
face de la médaille les ont donc c'est
une manière et qui se rapproche au géant
frontil cergy de l'enfance oui mais il
se trouve aussi que ce jeu de l'enfance
en vérité a une signification parfois
tragique dans la vie oui bien sûr parce
que ça ça donne les découvertes qui
peuvent être et terrifiante et terrible
alors la première nouvelle qui est je
crois un peu autobiographique
en tout cas vous le dites dans la
préface c'est c'est un écrivain donc
c'est vous et vous allez au portugal
nous annoncer la mort de mario do carmo
et vous allez apprendre sur elle des
choses tout à fait inattendue qui sont
quasiment le contraire de ce que vous
connaissiez d'elle oui il s agissait de
descendants dans les livres et d'un
personnage sait vaguement
autobiographique bien sûr mais mais très
vaguement c'est un personnage qui qui
aimait beaucoup faire léger de l'envers
même dans la vie et pour sa propre vie
pour sa part privée bien firent donc
incertain à un moment donné et
l'investigateur 10 on découvre des
choses qui ne sont ni ne suffisait pas
et il est vrai que se sachant qu'elle
allait mourir
elle laisse un mot pour le décrire le
guardiola s'est montré ambigu qui est
mots sévères qui paie est très liée à l
inverse vers ce que smb er mai qui donne
pas un roman français rêve oui ce qui
permet de rêver oui ce qui permet de
rêver sur sur sa vie sur ce qu'elle
faisait sur sa manière d'être
alors il y en a bien une nouvelle qui
est formidable c'est un fou
shakespearien en buzzant big une sorte
de type qui connaît une histoire vraie
qui sans vrai aussi rimer on me l'a
raconté on me l'a racontée et c c'est
mon beau père qui me l'a racontée est
une histoire la berge
c'est une histoire à beauvais c'est un
métier et anglais qui était un acteur
shakespearien qui a certainement un
certain moment et départ
et partie de la civilisation de la
partie de l'europe
il sait en france et dans l'afrique il a
continué à jouer son rôle d'acteur
shakespearien 100 personnes avec un
unique spectateurs c'est ça mais
effectivement c'est le jeu de l'envers
oui c'est gégé la mère et l'autre
nouvelle que je trouve très remarquable
c'est que cette étude paradis c'est laid
c'est une madame eu perte qui est très
cultivé très raffiné et qui engage une
sorte de demoiselle de compagnie dont
elle exige elle aussi la culture la
langue un bon maniement de la langue
française et c est là qu elle est le jeu
d'anvers est finalement cette dame est
très raffinée et très
est très fine et très très polis et elle
cache quelque chose de solide parce que
son mari c'est des trafics qui ne sont
pas claires oui elle apprend la jeune
fille quelque chose que j'ignorais son
ikebana c'est alors l'ikebana cette une
c'est une forme et raffinée de disposer
les fleurs et les lyonnaises à la
japonaise leader derrière l'ikebana
d'ailleurs cette culture d'ailleurs ce
raffinement
derrière ces conversations si bel et
bien on trouve la vulgarité et la
rapacité
oui la rapacité lait crémeux peut être
les crises voudrait c'est le jeu de
lambert je crois que oui le fil de
l'horizon c'est un court roman alors là
le héros c'est un c'est un détective qui
s'appelle d'ailleurs speedo évidemment
ça fait penser à spinoza
oui c'était c'est un détective c'est pas
un détective privé disons c'était ces
choses est une personne qui joue à
découvrir quelque chose oui il se trouve
être un des indes est un décret tease
parce qu'il est ils découvrent un
cadavre inconnue et il veut donner une
identité au cadavre mais oui mais alors
tout va se dérégler toute son enquête va
pas se brouiller
oui parce que c'est un psg de la vère
aussi face à la c'est aussi un jeu
d'anvers ce texte soit plus très bien
dans l'autre normes n'ont normalement
dans les romans policiers traditionnel
on accepte par parfaitement les rôles
deux détectives personne ne pose des
questions sur les tubes de l'été tu es
là il est donné
il est il n'a pas besoin des
interrogations disons l'intervention
principal principal durement du petit
roman c'est l'interrogation qui est un
certain moment on se pose sur les
investigateurs
c'est à dire que l'en quête des rails au
lieu d'enquêter socadap finalement il
enquête sur lui même sur lui même dont
s'étend aussi oui le le jeu de 2011
c'est un détournement c'était ces
quelques chaises oblique qui sait pas
c'est lui
un chercheur quelqu'un il cherche même
là vous faites souvent des références
littéraires là il ya la figure à lille i
à ce grand poète portugais vous êtes le
spécialiste we pessoa un vaisseau afin
de pessoa qui vient de paraître
maintenant en force en france
la france veut dire j'ai oublié j'aurais
dû les apporté j'ai oublié mes excuses
et donc je suis les traducteurs italien
de ces poètes
donc je suis dit est très lié au pc pour
être c'est formidable oui je les trouve
les plus grands poètes du siècle
compétition c'est pour moi c'est le plus
grand poète pas que oui formation de
tous qu'un pas d'avis à ces actes louis
qui connaissez vous michaelle jean pas
du tout non pas du tout mais voilà ça va
je vais aller chercher
il est traduit en anglais
petit jeu mais c'est quintanilla je
pense c'est cette annonce et m6 avec un
homme
espagnols et il a une petite vision dans
l'épais books c'est aussi mais en france
maintenant on l'étend lettre on l'a
presque tous traduits avec les éditions
bourgois vous avez vu les oui il ya eu
on a publié aussi un
un journal qui est presque un roman je
pense qu'elle le livre de
l'intranquillité et vous vous disiez des
plus grands poètes européen du siècle le
plus grand poète portugais
non non non le grand poète européenne il
y a une tradition l'espagnol qui a fait
un tableau parce que c'est formidable
oui c'est bien l'ancien est libre et
c'est que j'appelle quadri biou s'il
vous plaît je connais l'état de droit
que ses temps libres j'ai connu que je
dois être le plagiat les français c'est
un niveau incroyable antonio tabucchi et
c'est l'envers des choses envers des
êtres
est ce que ça ne rejoint pas d'une
certaine manière ces portes magiques que
recherche le héros de monsieur et je
crois que tous les toute l'écriture et
tous les écrivains reichert recherche
offrant l'un porte magique l'écriture et
c'est cet hymne c'était cette recherche
d'un petit miracle des misérables miami
raclée comme il est dur et michou
michaud pourvus pour ouvrir une porte
qui peut être n'existe pas mais c'est
c'est une tentative en match on va pour
tentative à l'écriture n'existe pas cela
que nos avec nous je reçois très souvent
des écrivains italiens j'ai toujours
fait signer parce qu'ils parlent tous le
français steve hooker but ça vous êtes
vie au portugal
j'évite au portugal oui mais l'a
admirablement fortune il y a une culture
latine